[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys we are currently off the
record oh wow although everything we say
will go on the record for anything that
can be used against us in the court of
law always interesting
but that's why we're careful boys
because we stay careful with what we say
so welcome to exhibit a
uh in light of all the news happening
right now with amber heard and johnny
depp rather than just regurgitate all
the little details that have been
popping up i thought it would be cool to
just kind of share our own stories
of abusive relationships that we might
hey
that would be cool that's a yay no you
know what's crazy is like if you've been
through one or seen some people close to
you do this [ __ ]
when you see amber heard in like johnny
depp it's like
that's like the [ __ ] textbook
dictionary example of exactly like the
[ __ ] that goes down you're just like
holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ] nuts dude have
you been through winnie everybody poops
on their
ex significant others no but like the
[ __ ] sabotage the lies the because
like there's this one thing about um how
have you heard about her her putting
nail polish like in a nap yeah to act
like she's bleeding [ __ ] you [ __ ]
hit me so hard i'm bleeding [ __ ]
and it's like no no but then like those
crazy like examples right yeah like
i've seen that happen to people close to
me and i'm like you need to get the [ __ ]
out and they're like i can't i'm scared
like this one girl um in high school she
was [ __ ] nuts and they'll have an
argument and then she just started like
turning [ __ ] like turning on the
lighter on their cigarette the cigarette
lighter they started burning the car
inside we're gonna burn i'm gonna burn
us inside this whole thing the chick was
doing that the she was doing it scared
the dude yeah it's not a good way to
burn a car though but then she's here
she would also threaten
like to tell all his boys all her
friends that he's beating her because
you know back in the day like guys if
they heard that yeah they're like oh she
did what and then they'll like [ __ ] them
up yeah and then so that's like that
that made him scared to like i can't
break up with her dude like every time
like i try to say anything or whatever
like
i just i don't know man she's [ __ ]
nuts that's crazy in like the 90s and
early 2000s
the
no one thought girls could lie
so the minute a girl said one thing
dudes got straight jumped by like eight
other dudes yeah it was crazy yeah
this was just said in the 90s and 2000s
girls couldn't lie that's the consensus
at the time that same arrow girls never
pooped or farted either for real nah i
seen them [ __ ] that's a late 2000's
thing
that's true though if a homegirl like in
high school yeah if they were like man
that guy you know you don't know like he
beats me he [ __ ] yells at me no
questions asked they'll be like oh
seriously all right [ __ ] this [ __ ] and
then don't like tell other guys or
whatever and then just [ __ ] catch
them and smack them up you know and then
they think that they're gonna get the
[ __ ] now probably yeah of course
probably gotta save her or it's just uh
it's just the honor factor too like it
might be someone's sister or whatever
like and it's just like oh you just
gotta do it and i'm like damn that's
crazy because everybody just immediately
went [ __ ] this [ __ ] let's kill him and
that's kind of how it happened with
amber heard when she went with her
expose everyone was like [ __ ] johnny
depp then you know i know there's i
think there's something wired in guys to
want to innately also protect not just
want to [ __ ] but also protect for some
reason like this is like this is
something we gotta do or everyone just
automatically believes the female right
away well i never think to to think that
that's being done by someone who i
consider as a friend like if i don't
think girls are trying to manipulate me
to think like you know uh uh let's use
him to do violence on him because i just
[ __ ] mad at him like i never that's
just too crazy to think did you guys
immediately go like oh johnny depp [ __ ]
him i didn't really know because when it
first came out i was like this is so
weird because well what happens behind
closed doors we all know like celebs and
all that like who knows who they really
are so it could happen
but then at the same time it's like
when i mean celebrity [ __ ] and crazy
things that happen behind closed doors
there's always so much stuff that goes
down that it nothing surprises me
anymore
but also at that time right like so many
others
yeah high profile people were getting
called out so like by the time and i'm
not trying to say that i'm like
so emotionally desensitized but you kind
of get that way with social media just
like throwing it down your [ __ ] face
right and it's just like oh johnny depp
2 it wasn't even like dude this guy you
know it's not like a single moment right
so i think um
he was just in a laundry list of just
another name
but it was one of those like oh johnny
depp really but other than that you
don't think like amber must be lying you
just don't think that i mean people
like being surprised at certain
celebrities being abusive is kind of
like
wow of course like why would you there's
some times where you guys ever had a
friend
like that was very like a personal
friend that was like a super nice guy
you would never imagine him doing that
and then years later
you know his girl and she goes oh dude
that guy used to beat me up so i used to
get hit like i i know people in my life
that were like that i had no clue i
don't know [ __ ] about johnny depp i
don't even know [ __ ] about this guy i've
seen relationships so we had a friend um
i think she was like a little bit more
independent
at an earlier age so she had like an
apartment by herself and she was like
running her um
parents like cabinet construction since
she was in high school so like i was
like a 17 or 18 year old like she
already had like a three bedroom
apartment so everyone of course is
that's like the safe haven right like
people go there to crash or whatever
and then there was this couple that
would always go there and it was
probably one of the most roller coastery
um relationships i've ever seen oh that
sounds fun yeah because it was it was
both ways sometimes it's like like guy
traps girl girl traps guy guy or girl
wants to leave um they can't leave
whatever this one was like fight both
people throw [ __ ] all over the house
trashed her house
um and then like one wants to leave it's
not even her house i know that's the
product sucks the other one wants to
leave no come back whatever and then all
of a sudden
amongst the friends they're so good now
they love each other then the next time
they get into a fight in the car um the
dude's driving and he goes if i can't
have you then we both don't live and he
crashes into a street light
and um and then you're like okay for
sure this time it's done because now the
parents are involved they crashed her
car the car is done and then they're
like they're back together again and it
was just like almost every point where
on my like i guess
ruler of reason checklist i'm like oh i
would have been out i would have been
out i would have been out like seven
times
never been out and it was also so toxic
to the point where
you couldn't really go okay this person
is
slightly more evil than this person like
bully victim you couldn't really find
the bully victim relationship it was
just like man both of these guys are
either like perfect for each other or
they're really bad for each other that
was crazy there's an age due where
you're just like dude i can't imagine my
life without this person yeah and it's
like such an emotional um and you say
that with stitches on your face
we can make it work you know you say
that to the doctor in the er
it's intense though like that i remember
being in high school and like getting
like my first like serious girlfriend
and just thinking having those thoughts
of like i could never imagine my life
without this chick and like you're just
so emotional physical reaction almost
sometimes oh just it was more just like
you you just feel like um any argument
you get in you feel like your heart's
like gonna come out of your chest and
like fall on the ground or something
like it's a very intense time for you
hormonally and [ __ ] i think again i can
super relate to to that too
i think um
you know like a lot of couples
in in high school specifically you just
want to experience all the highs and
lows that you get into such a dramatic
tumultuous [ __ ] just to feel alive like
in some of these scenarios and i was in
a lot of [ __ ] like that where
i was in relationships where like my
exes hit me with a car because she was
like i'm out of here and i went no
and then i jumped in front of you you
jumped into the car and like i'm jumping
into it and she hit me with a car
i've done like all that [ __ ] just
because like for some [ __ ] weird
reason it's like i wanted to understand
what those like uh i guess what all of
those spectrum of feelings are that you
see so much in movies yeah and tv and
[ __ ] and it kind of like plagues you a
little bit but i think you're like
that's what passion is yeah cause you
don't know any different right you just
approach it from like a telenovela
standpoint you're like dude that's
probably how you do it but then uh when
you get older and you're still doing
that [ __ ] that's where i'm like come on
i was doing that a trial and error of
like i don't know what's right yeah but
it's like eventually you gotta reach a
point yeah so guys should probably stop
the plane huh
i guess this is good it's gonna be hard
but
you gotta talk to homeland security
worth it though
i'm trying to [ __ ] suck her up in a
turbine and [ __ ]
you know even even on lesser scales like
i've definitely like had friends that
have been in like long
you know long relationships where they
just like break up get back together
break up gets back together there's
times where you know they're like
drunk and just yelling at each other
like a girl just slap a dude in the face
like hit me again i like seen this [ __ ]
you know like but i lived with people
that do this and then the next day
they're just [ __ ] like cuddling on
the couch and stuff and everything's
great and you're just like are you
talking about korean couples i i've you
never come and vietnamese you never
confront them like yo you guys might be
cool but what about me [ __ ] i
just had to [ __ ] witness your
[ __ ] now i'm traumatized from that
[ __ ] some people like doing that the
collateral damage is crazy it's like
they act like oh aren't you happy for us
no you [ __ ] live in your own goddamn
bubble dude we all had to hear that [ __ ]
last night we had to [ __ ] hang out
with you for eight hours and like talk
you through your relationship and now
you're so much better because it's been
35 minutes yeah and now everybody else
should feel relieved yeah just [ __ ]
chill out shut the [ __ ] up and by the
way who broke my favorite glass like i
know why'd you smash my ming voz
and they turn around and they turn
around start giving you a relationship
advice right oh my god
what the [ __ ] you guys last night was a
nightmare
now you guys don't get all figured out
huh but i mean i could only imagine when
it gets way more toxic or way more
intense or different people had
different upbringings and have been
exposed to different things so they
treat different situations differently
because yeah when i when i do see things
like the johnny depp and amber heard
stuff
me i'm like that's [ __ ] crazy you
know what i mean
in the bed yeah slash like you're on
like every [ __ ] drug out there
because maybe there's also accessibility
too right like if you have the ability
whether it be the freedom to actually go
you know on some sort of trip that has
all these drugs and whatnot and then
things kind of escalate and get out of
get out of hand like that's a whole
different realm a whole different tier
of like toxic
possibilities she's blowing 40 g's a
month on wine dude that's isn't that
crazy
imagine what the pills and like all the
[ __ ] drugs and alcohol how can you
even is she buying [ __ ] the top notch
top shelf craziest [ __ ] about like 100k
130 racks and a month well for wine
that's not even super super top wine
gets so expensive oh really i think what
you develop a palette where you only
want good wine too that's yeah and she's
probably buy that the way i buy
chapstick or i buy like four at a time
yeah that's what they said you're a
baller though it's different four
chapsticks one in my car because that's
how bothered i am i don't like get one
there's two on you i got one of my
backpacks
one of my trucks i'm just gonna engineer
you one where it's all connected and
forward like this they just make one big
one
so he's constantly just yeah if you get
through him that fast that'll probably
be better for you
i keep it everywhere i keep that that's
that's how ballin
i don't remember the last time i used a
whole stick of chapstick dude it's
always like a quarter and i [ __ ]
disappear you always lose it i find it
melted in the dryer
the son of a [ __ ] i got that idea from
diddy because he uh shout out to diddy
because one time he was talking about
how he only buys six cds at a time and
then they're like wait why he goes i'm
not gonna take the same cd from my car
into my house into whatever so i just
buy it so it's in everything i gotta go
bankrupt by diddy and i was like
damn that's cool we're talking about cds
and then [ __ ] chapsticks
i'm fun balling like that that's true
bro well i do the same thing with phone
chargers
i have one in the car i have one by the
bed i have one in my backpack it's so
weird but those break like crazy too so
you know they're perishable did any of
you guys have uh were your parents
like a good role model in terms of like
romantic relationships or did any of
them were any of them toxic that should
be you know what
my this is what blows my mind because
usually like violent dads right they
beat the [ __ ] out of their wives their
whole family right
i've only seen my mom smack my dad
and he was always sweet to her wow yeah
so then when he gets smacked what was it
like was he like he just excused himself
or they were fighting in the car and
then she just wham smacks him in his
face and then i was in the back seat and
i said stop the fighting
yeah and then they stopped like a unicef
representative
yeah and then i felt brave because i was
like oh [ __ ] that stopped it
yeah i don't know i was a little kid
back then but then i was like crying in
the car and i was like you gotta stop
fighting there's too much fighting in
this [ __ ] house
um but then he just went red face and he
just like he just he was quiet he was
just quiet he was just like completely
just still but i never seen him beat her
up or anything like that
um and then like they would be pda but
then it would gross me out when i was a
kid so i was like uh no and i would make
them stop and [ __ ]
and then so they could make you happy
dude yeah
they would be private with their pda
afterwards but yeah that's why you broke
them up huh probably that's like broken
oh me man
my parents when i was taika's age the
[ __ ] blocked my dad the most like clear
memory i have of like a big fight
was um yeah i was like three or four and
like they were getting [ __ ] pissed
and then i saw my dad throw a apple
um i was too young to remember if it was
at her or if it was just at the wall
like out of anger like an apple laptop
no like apple fruit juicy like a caramel
green apple yeah
a candied and then
candied apples and i remember just
crying like i didn't even i didn't know
how to register like
our little like family pot having that
kind of anger or whatever and i just was
like like frozen and i didn't even know
really know how to like process that
time was crazy you know what um i
remember i was i was talking to my
friends about this whole like like you
know parents like fighting and [ __ ]
right and they're all like yeah man like
they're all bonding over there like
dad's beating their moms and [ __ ] and
i'm all like damn that's [ __ ] up right
and then i told him my story i was like
yeah man my mom she slapped my dad and
then there they started clowning me and
they're like that's cause our dad's not
a [ __ ] and i'm like wait what
that's the right answer
the asian kings of comedy our dad
doesn't take [ __ ] from our mom dude yeah
he ends it she starts it he ends it yeah
that's a real guy right there that was
the moment when i realized man my
friends are [ __ ] stupid dude dude you
want to know [ __ ] uh that's also why
people with trauma they connect well too
and then sometimes it pulls each other
down because there's not another person
to come and elevate you know it's like
both of them are like nah we like it
when our dads beat our moms and they
normalize it because what else yeah and
then it's a vicious cycle because then
they start beating their girls because
they they think that's normal they think
that's how life is supposed to be you're
a man like my dad beat me very cool yeah
it went from like oh man he [ __ ]
beats her that's just scary and this is
that and then i was like oh what my mom
sh she hit my dad but not that not the
other way around he didn't do [ __ ]
they're like oh cause he's a [ __ ] he
didn't do nothing back and i was like
why is that something you're proud of
now i didn't give you a complex growing
up you're like damn my dad's a [ __ ] dog
no i thought they were [ __ ] crazy
[Laughter]
who the [ __ ] turns it around and wants
their dad to [ __ ] up good thing you were
smart yeah because some kids would be
like dude my dad is a [ __ ] because with
that mob mentality and like those are
your closest yeah it's really easy to be
like oh [ __ ] and it's easy to go back
home and like dad hit her back
defend yourself i'm not going to say
anything go ahead next time your mom
slides to dad it's just like hey my
friends think you're a [ __ ] because you
don't hit her back don't stand up to
this woman
you let her hit you like that disrespect
you i think there's like a strange
complex that uh i feel like i had this
and if there's other guys that have this
uh definitely check yourself um i never
hit a single like girl that i've been
with like i've always had a code of like
that's just not what you do
and i think like um
in my mind it was like if you're hitting
your girl then you've entered a lower
class
so then i was just like it's just not
you know like as much as you're fighting
you just never get to that point
but
what i think
sounds funny
however kicking is not hitting that's
right yeah flash kicking is not included
suplex is a wee-wee back now you're two
females and it's okay
i have a good loophole
i think if you're like a young person
like for me i was like 16 17 and and i
think like at a young age when i'm like
yeah i i never hit my girl i think that
gave me a form of elitism in my brain
where i said
okay yeah i'm never gonna physically hit
you and it gave me a weird point of
pride but
i'm gonna mentally [ __ ] with you
so far to get that like so healthy it's
because i didn't i didn't take care of
the source of aggression yeah i just
channeled it through other means like
i'm not going to punch you so you got to
clap back and make another one like hell
you know like and that's i used to do
that i'm going to close the cell door on
your ass oh [ __ ]
you got to just go with flinching you
just got to do one of these sometimes
that's crazy like if any i think like if
any guy's like man i don't hit my girl
like that's for wimps or whatever it's
like dude make sure you know that you're
not
you know exerting that through some
other form of torture because that's
when you know that's when guys get so
used to like mentally abusing or
verbally abusing which is just as bad
yeah while they're doing it they're like
it's always a thing of at least i'm not
sucking in the face like this dude or at
least i'm not like a good guy yeah good
guy tm
yeah that's that i remember dude i
remember being such an immature little
[ __ ] but um
my big move was like
oh well i'm breaking up with you and
it's like
you know what i mean like that that
whole like you're never you're never
gonna feel comfortable in our
relationship because i'll just break up
with you every time i disagree with you
yeah yeah holding you hostage right yeah
yeah and then it's like and then it's
like yeah all right well we're back
together it's fine you know what i mean
like you just once you get what you want
it doesn't mean anything it doesn't mean
yeah it doesn't mean anything but that
is another form of of doing that for
sure i would also agree with ryan like i
think um same thing right we just have
that code where it's like you won't
physically
abuse a girl but then like you're
like the worst tendencies i've ever had
in relationships was verbal abuse you
know what i mean because i was the only
way to get that same aggression out and
and feel
some some piece of [ __ ]
like concept of controller power you
know to me or defense in your mind so
you know like needing to get checked
about like that as well has been
something that like i i remember
still even like still stuff i gotta like
work on you know because when you get
angry you just
you get loud because you don't want to
break [ __ ] because you think that that's
your your way of control but at the end
of the day you still get angry you know
so you still gotta yeah like you said
work on like that aggression i didn't
even know verbal abuse was a thing
yeah it's one of those things where what
do you mean you're just so used to it i
think
i didn't even know sexual abuse was a
thing either not like if if you like if
you hear the word it just sounds like
made up yeah like it is like how is that
abuse right like yeah how can you hurt
someone because it when i heard the word
i was like
i only know of like abuse in the
physical form i didn't know there were
other kinds and then how do you even
mark bart verbally visits me every day
here yeah but that's a love it's because
we grew up with the sticks and stones
saying you know what i mean like it's
it's hard to like look at verbal dicks
and sounds may break my bones but verbal
abuse sucks worse yeah
but it's a concept that it's like you
think it's out of bounds or you're
allowed to do it yeah because you don't
think that it's harmful or it's not a
thing until you realize how much it can
damage someone then it's like
yeah obviously that makes sense but if
everyone's doing it
then it's normalized and i think that's
the thing like if you if you could think
about what the hell amber heard had to
go through like growing up what kind of
childhood did she have to where she has
to create this persona where she's never
herself and then
she also thinks it's okay
to [ __ ] be completely abusive to all
her partners that are madly in love with
her so it's like what kind of i mean you
know
human grows up this way i think that's
what i want to know because i'm like
what did what happened in their
childhood for them to
become who they are it comes from
somewhere right it usually is from
childhood or it's like maybe maybe she
was always like that and was never
checked like super permissive parents
because that can happen too it's like
not always from trauma she gets gaslit
she gaslights her parents and [ __ ] yeah
and now she's just trying to be
heard
i hate that we have to end it here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you